it was a day straight out of a horror
movie
it had rained the day prior and the fog
filled the air of the Blue Ridge
Mountains
as expected I had no signal so my GPS
had stopped working
and I was lost
I had to get to my patient's home but
the directions the family gave me landed
me straight in the middle of a bumpy
dirt road covered by the forest fog
I had no way to call for help and I
worried if my small car would get stuck
in the mud puddles and suddenly I'm
approached by a one-eyed man with
tattoos covering his arms and his right
hand
holding the gun on his hip he threatens
me to leave his property
I paused
this was the moment I had been preparing
for
this was a crucial conversation hey
everyone I'm yesi and on this channel we
talk about minimalism and how to live a
happier more fulfilling life with less
so if you want to hear how I not only
dissueded the city decision so that I
could leave safely but also obtain that
man's help twice that day be sure to
stick to the end to find out and if
minimalism and adopting positive habits
sounds interesting to you be sure to
subscribe for more videos aimed at
helping you live a happier more
meaningful life this book is one that I
have read and reread because I love it
that much but I first read it about four
years ago when I worked as an ICU nurse
and I began to feel stagnant I felt that
it was time for me to do something more
and pursue leadership positions so I
began precepting training for more
critical patients and obtained my
certification in ICU but I knew that all
of these things would be in vain if I
did not work on improving one thing my
communication skills as an introvert who
struggled with self-confidence this
became my focus I read this book slowly
over the course of several weeks and I
did this intentionally because I did not
want it to just be another self-help
book that I just kind of mindlessly went
through I wanted to actually apply it to
my life and I eventually left ICU for
home hospice nursing and working in jobs
that literally face life and death
situations on a daily basis what a
better way for me than to practice
crucial conversations than on the job
but crucial conversations happen every
day lesson one recognizing a crucial
conversation the book starts off by
explaining what is a crucial
conversation because it doesn't have to
be a life and death situation it is one
where three things take place one
opinions vary so maybe there's an
argument or some issue to resolve number
two the stakes are high the outcome of
this conversation will either have
positive or negative effects in your
life this isn't just talking about the
weather here and number three strong
emotions are present you may find
yourself feeling angry defensive or
afraid so for example think an argument
with a spouse asking for a promotion
ending a relationship or resolving an
issue with a co-worker or client the
book defines them as the day-to-day
conversations that affect your life my
conversation with this man definitely
checked all the check boxes but luckily
for me I had already been practicing the
first step in the book which was to
recognize that this was a crucial
conversation because how often do we
enter an argument and immediately let
our emotions rule we either attack the
other person or avoid the conversation
altogether and it all crumbles apart and
this is precisely why I paused and
allowed myself to Exhale before I
responded this way I could respond with
intelligence rather than with emotion
lesson number two focus on what you
really want and know what you don't want
this may sound really simple and obvious
but it is so important in my situation
what I wanted was to get to my patients
home safely what I did not want was to
leave the property without having
accomplished this goal and of course the
most obvious I didn't want anybody
getting hurt knowing what it is that I
wanted to accomplish out of this
conversation allowed me with the right
frame of mind so that this way I did not
either react with fear or aggression it
gave me a sort of visual frame in which
direction to focus the conversation what
this does is it takes the perspective
from the bickering back and forth
between two people or two groups and it
instead focuses it on the issue lesson
number three know your communication
style this book has a short quiz to help
you know your default reactions when
faced with a challenging conversation
for some it's attacking and controlling
for me it had always been avoiding and
withdrawal knowing this about myself I
knew that if I defaulted to apologizing
and cowarding down and leaving I wasn't
going to accomplish my goal I wasn't
going to see this patient that urgently
needed my services and today was not the
day that I was going to back down I had
something that I wanted to accomplish
and I needed this man's help to do so so
my next step was to dissuade the emotion
lesson number four is to step out make
it safe then step back in my first
response was to calmly apologize for
intruding and explain my reason for
being there but I also needed his help
and because he was clearly angry I had
to step outside the situation I had to
see his perspective what was he feeling
was he feeling disrespected or
threatened what was his motive what did
he want stepping outside the situation
for a moment and looking at it as though
I was watching it happen allowed myself
to remain calm while I was speaking to
him because it wasn't about defending
myself or attacking him it was about
getting what we both wanted while
maintaining respect lesson number five
is crucial maintain respect but how can
I maintain respect for somebody that is
clearly showing no respect for me
because if I default to cursing or
allowing my emotions to rule the
conversation I am showing that I have no
control I have no power power can be
defined as the ability to influence the
way people act or think having a calm
yet firm voice exudes confidence
allowing the other person to feel the
same in the conversation and be open to
negotiation by contrast if there's
simply a war between who can yell the
loudest or hit the hardest the other
individual simply defaults to their own
fight-or-flight method and nothing gets
resolved before we continue let me know
in the comments what's one crucial
conversation you have handled in a
positive manner and how did you do it
I'd love to hear from you lesson number
six use amp ask questions mirror
paraphrase and Prime it's one thing to
listen intently to the other person and
capture what they're really trying to
say as well as understanding their
motives and it's a whole nother ordeal
to actually show them that you're
capturing what they're saying people
want to be heard they want to be
understood and the book goes into detail
in certain skills to practice to briefly
describe them ask
start by simply expressing interest in
the other person's views so instead of
taking over and you ruling the
conversation ask questions to get them
to open up and give you information in
my case what I used was a lot of
mirroring and paraphrasing mirror
increased safety by respectfully
acknowledging the emotions people appear
to be feeling I didn't beat around the
bush I calmly said you are very upset
right now this simple phrase allowed
this man to open up like a can of worms
and he began telling me about his
frustration with delinquency in the area
and something about politics and even
though he had just threatened my life I
listened this wasn't about me I also use
paraphrasing which is basically taking
what they just told you and restating it
in your own words this shows them that
you're truly engaged and that you're
truly capturing what they're saying and
lastly priming if others continue to
hold back Prime take your best guess at
what they may be thinking and feeling
open-ended statements in priming is what
I especially love to use with my hospice
patients and their families when they
appear to be holding back on their pain
or grief this is things like this has
been a difficult time for you or it
appears that you're feeling afraid
notice that I didn't outright ask are
you afraid which a person could just
reply yes or no an open-ended statement
or question allows the other person to
clarify and expand lesson number seven
listen this is truly the most powerful
lesson of all but it is easier said than
done a truly exceptional
conversationalist listens first and
speaks second once you have heard your
counterpart it makes it much more likely
that they will listen to you and hear
your perspective using the tools
mentioned in this book will help you
learn how to let the other person know
that they have been heard and it makes
it much more likely that you will leave
the conversation having accomplished
your goal so what ended up happening
that day this man talked to me on and on
about the issues that he had been having
and his view on Politics as well and he
told me the way to go but somehow as
though my day couldn't get any more fun
I drove around and ended up right back
to him a second time this time he was
more angry and then he had become
suspicious so I validated his concern I
mirrored I listened and this time he
guided me to where I needed to go wow
talk about the power of effective
communication if you are interested in
obtaining this book I will include the
link to it down in the description but I
also have an affiliate link for a free
30-day trial as well as a free audiobook
from audible which is an online platform
where you can gain access to over a
hundred and eighty thousand audiobooks
podcasts and Originals you can cancel at
any time but if you do decide to use it
it does help to support my channel so
thank you in advance and if you want to
learn more on the topic of improving
your communication skills two books that
I highly recommend are Evie pompeira's
book becoming bulletproof life lessons
from a secret service agent and hostage
negotiator Chris bosses never split the
difference they are both badass
conversationalists that share with you
how to successfully get what you want
without ever needing to use force and
I'll include the link to both of these
in the description box below and that's
it for today's video thank you so much
for your time and don't forget to Thumbs
Up And subscribe so you won't miss when
I post a new video till next time bye
for now
[Music]
[Music]